attention cette vidéo utilise la
technologie de la troisième dimension
allez c'est parti ouais c'est sympa
ouais bah moi je n'ai pas de barre mais
ça c'est parce que je me rase tous les
matins au en général la barbe ça arrive
vers 15-16 ans chez les ados bon jeu
certains c'est un peu plus tôt rien oui
mais quand à 24 ans n'a toujours pas de
barbe
tu te poses des questions
je me pose des questions les barbus
j'aime bien me dire un truc qui m'énerve
tellement non en fait c'est super chiant
de se raser tous les matins mec pas vos
os et de la chance de ne pas avoir de
marbre j'ai peur mais c'est trop chiant
de se raser tous les matins avec ah bon
ah ouais t'es trop de chance d'être
encore un enfant
en fait quand on dit qu'on est imberbe
on n'est pas vraiment imberbe et fait
c'est des poils que nous seuls on sait
qu'on a en fait t'as pas de barres de
toit si un petit peu quand même là fait
voir un jeu faut plutôt regarder cela il
a attend tu vas pas là non ah ah ouais
tu vas chez veolia attend et norman qui
montrent qu'il ya un poil mer
carrément fait grand galet ans avant de
déposer sa mémère mais on sera quand
même faut pas croire
moi par exemple je me rase une fois tous
les une fois je me suis rasé une fois
mais avec de la mousse on est tous
vraiment
non même jour se rendent pas compte mais
quand est imberbe et des situations où
la vie te veut du mal et norman ça me
dit si bien la soirée cure moustache
faut juste avoir un blouson en cuir et
une moustache
on peut venir avec une fausse moustache
ou non non c'est ridicule ça crois-tu
devant sa annonce comme ça je vais
absents fait ça toi ça pousse ah non non
non quand t'as pas de barbe a
naturellement tu fais un peu plus jeunes
c'est bien connu les camps de base déjà
tu fais à ces jeunes de visages bas avec
les meufs
c'est plutôt cool même charge il a plus
de bars que moi sacrément dans la
société et les amis se rate complètement
le visage donc dans la rue les mecs qui
sont en berne comme moi va saigner vu ni
connu
mais heureusement je suis pas née à
l'époque du passé à l'attaqué weezy vas
tu as tu viens pas toi t'as pas de barbe
est une femme
maintenant je suis un homme et une femme
le c'est du sexisme en tout cas de plus
en plus nombreux sur la page facebook
norman fait des vidéos et que vous soyez
père boit un verre ça me fait super
plaisir
vous êtes double super
[Musique]